if you're still smiling from ear to ear
over netflix's latest series heart
stopper which has earned itself a 100
rating on rotten tomatoes then trust us
you're not alone this wholesome lgbtq
plus coming of age series is a
refreshing take on a young queer love
story but now that you've finished
binging it you're probably wondering
what to watch next to fill the void
until heart stopper season 2 drops does
this mean my boyfriend
yes
was that already established the last 10
times we made out and lucky for you
we're breaking down five shows you need
to watch if you loved heartstopper
to start things off we have the popular
netflix spanish teen drama elite each
season of elite revolves around a
mysterious crime however crime aside the
series has some fantastic lgbtq plus
representations among its main cast with
characters such as omar and ander
rebecca and mencia plus patrick and ivan
dare we say the queer cast carry the
show elite is certainly made for a more
mature audience but once you've
graduated from heartstopper we think
it's time to give elite a try
[Music]
young royals is a swedish netflix show
about a troubled young prince named
wilhelm who is sent to boarding school
for royal youth of nobility and status
that's until he meets simon a singer in
the school's choir and the two quickly
start to fall in love but be warned
young royals has a much darker tone
compared to heartstopper as it tackles
topics such as hazing drug abuse sex and
living up to high expectations
i'm gay
oh god you're not saying anything
netflix's never have i ever follows the
life of davey a daughter of an immigrant
indian couple who moved to the united
states who is trying to navigate the
everyday struggles of being the child of
an immigrant navigate a love triangle in
high school and deal with the trauma of
her father's unexpected passing
you kissing your father's ashes have
barely begun to drift out to sea i just
got overcome with emotion what are you
gonna do at my funeral just have sex on
top of my grave i pray it's a closed
casket aside from davey's journey we
follow the journey of fabiola who learns
to discover she's a lesbian after
falling in love with a girl named
[Music]
is everything all right we were just um
we're doing karate so
sex education is a quintessential
netflix teen show and if you love the
cutest of heart stopper but crave just a
little more comedic humor then look no
further the show follows otis milburn
whose mother is a sex therapist and
through this he becomes an informal sex
therapist for his classmates otis best
friend eric is an out and proud gay man
who's often bullied by adam for his
queerness that is until adam and eric
form a relationship the show encompasses
all the elements of a coming of age
series from coming out gender identity
and so much more
[Music]
mom
dad
i'm gay last but not least we have love
victor the spin-off series from the
popular film love simon in the series
victor exchanges messages with the now
graduated simon seeking his help and
advice with navigating coming out and of
course
what's high school without a love
triangle love victor is streaming on
disney plus and the show is currently
filming its final third season say the
word and i will ditch these gays like a
corporation after pride month
you